where did you come from I want to build
a new future serial is the wall where
are you going sweetheart many gentleman
gentleman is my journey started in
Serbia just a few hundred yards away
from the Hungarian border and I crossed
with this man walking with a stick in
the pouring rain he was making
incredibly slow progress across the
border I think for me this picture sums
up really good journey that so many
thousands of people have made and my
name is [ __ ] I'm Syrian come on
Damascus I'm going anyplace can find a
new home people arrived in too hungry to
what was called a holding area it was an
absolute mud bath we saw children
running around playing in the mud others
crying clothes that have been brought by
volunteers but weren't needed or the got
soaked by the rain just lying on the
ground
from the holding area people queued for
buses where are you going on this box
you know the bus inside inside yeah they
were being taken to the makeshift
refugee camps that have been set up on
the border and if I walked along the
perimeter fence of one of them people
children adults press themselves up
against the wire fence [ __ ] hello no
hello buddy I love to my friends in
Syria you loose your friends yes how
much a very for those that managed to
avoid the police was just under a 200
kilometer journey many did it by foot to
Budapest the capital and the railway
station when I arrived first thing in
the morning this man was making the most
of the facilities on offer sounds 7 the
underpass under the station had become a
tented village of refugees I asked this
boy if I could take his picture and he
nodded much about being a buzzard manage
me and then as the day went on Hugh
stormed to board the train that would
take them to the Austrian holder wants
us to train to be full of yet you know
got a room in atomic
if the trains are unloaded in Haggerty
lon it was a three kilometer walk across
to the Austrian border and Nichols door
at the border crossing volunteers were
giving out food and drink with priority
given to women and children another day
another train station and Vienna was
packed with people boarding trains to
what would be for many of them their
final destination to Germany there was
sadness and anger to as I met this woman
from Cavani who was pregnant she told me
how she'd been beaten by the police in
hungary by nignog with hungary no no
good no good no good so many people I
met along this journey told me they
wanted to go to Germany because they
wanted freedom but now they've arrived
they still face an uncertain future